happy Halloween hey guys i'm abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen it is almost
one of my favorite holidays of the whole
year Halloween because let's be real
it's all about the candy and a chocolate
bar thinking back to my childhood during
Halloween when my sister and I used to
go out trick-or-treating
I would always sneak into a room when
she was unsuspecting sneak out all of my
favorite chocolate bars and like replace
them with like the tootsie rolls or like
the lollipops already the crap that
nobody really cares about or wants and
my go-to was definitely those mini
Snickers bars those are one of my
favorite chocolate bars of all time I
love the combination of nugget and
peanuts caramel and of course chocolate
so today I want to share with you a
healthier version these are my vegan
gluten-free no refined sugar added
Snickers bars they are so addictive that
you're definitely not gonna wanna just
wait till Halloween you're gonna want to
make these all year long so let's do
this to make the nougat I add some
almond flour peanut butter maple syrup
Winfrey oat flour and some coconut oil
to a food processor and I process that
until it gets really smooth
then to my baking dish I add some
parchment paper
and then I pack the Nugget into the
bottom of the baking dish
transfer that's the freezer to let it
set up for about ten minutes then to a
saucepot I add some medjool dates the
maple syrup and some coconut cream and I
simmer that on a medium low heat until
it all comes together
then transfer the dates to my food
processor and puree until super smooth
next I mix my date mixture some
chopped-up peanuts I give it a good stir
until it all comes together now it's
time to assemble my frozen nugget I add
my date caramel with peanuts and I
smooth it out and I transfer that to the
freezer for about an hour to set up and
now it's time for some chocolate I cut
my slab into some rectangular bars and
then carefully dip it into some melted
chocolate that I melted in the microwave
with just a little bit of coconut oil
[Music]
let it set on a piece of parchment paper
and joy
so guys I hope you enjoyed this video if
you did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with what kind
of candy bar you are going to be
stealing from your kids candy bags
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]